Hello ! Ouais, ça je voulais parler
d'une d'une discussion que j'ai eu avec
un membre de ma famille hier qui
concernant la liberté financière. On
parlait justement que une personne qu'on
connaissait qui avait 30 34 ans avait
avait arrêté de travailler puis av pris
sa retraite parce qu'il avait mis assez
d'argent de côté puis avait travaillé
euh très intense pendant sa vingtaine pu
sa trentaine pour atteindre un niveau
puis vivre de ses intérêts.
Donc c'est ce qui nous mettait à parler
de liberté financière parce qu'il y en
avait plusieurs qui disaient que tu peux
pas tu ne pouvais pas prendre une
retraite à 34 ans que c'était impossible
que je veux dire
tu pass pour vivre et cetera.
Puis ça me fait penser au jeu de Robert
Kyosaki qui est Cash Flow
donc
qui a deux phases au jeu. Tu la première
qui est la Race qui appelle Rat Race qui
est donc que tu travailles pour souvenir
tes besoins puis tu es comme obligé de
travailler à tous les jours à toutes les
semaines pour souvenir à tes besoins
puis que ton temps que ton temps de
travail c'est ta seule source de revenu.
Et dans la deuxième phase de vie, c'est
quand tu quand tu traverses la deuxième
phase, c'est que tu as eu assez
d'actifs. Tu as assez d'actifs qui te
génèrent du cashfow, de l'argent pour
subvenir à tes besoins. Donc le l'argent
que ça nécessite pour tes besoins
est moins élevé que l'argent que tu
génères avec tes actifs. Donc tes
actifs, c'est l'argent que tu crées sans
nécessairement travailler. soit des
investissements, soit de l'immobilier,
que ça soit c'est en bourse ou peu
importe un entreprise par exemple. Donc
vraiment avir de l'argent qui rentre
sans que tu a besoin de travailler. Puis
c'est quand tu passes du moment où c'est
que tu as plus d'actifs, tu as plus
d'argent qui est généré par tes actifs
que ton euh l'argent qui est nécessaire
pour avoir ton niveau de vie, que tu
traverses de l'autre côté. Puis l'autre
côté, c'est euh la deuxè vie qui
commence. On pourrait dire, c'est là que
tu te rends compte que l'argent c'est
pas ça qui est nécessaire pour ton
bonheur. Ça en fait partie mais c'est
pas ça qui va faire qui va donner un
sens à ta vie.
Donc c'est de traverser à ce moment-là
de ta vie où c'est que tu vas tomber un
peu en retraite de besoin de travailler
puis d'être salarié toute ta vie pour
subvenir à tes besoins.
Puis euh là ça reste mon humble habis
mais je pense que arriver le plus
rapidement possible dans sa vie à la
deuxème phase qui est le fait d'être
libre financièrement pour pouvoir te
poser les bonnes questions. Donc de OK,
maintenant que j'ai pas besoin d'argent
pour vivre, qu'est-ce que je vais faire
? Qu'est-ce que je vais faire pour
qu'est-ce qui me plaît vraiment à l'ur
de moi ? Qu'est-ce que je suis bon
dedans vraiment
que je dois me focus pour le reste de ma
vie ? Je pense qu' en a comme trop dans
leur vie qui vont rester tout le temps
dans la phase rat race qui vont juste
souvenir à leurs besoins puis même que
quand ils vont avoir plus d'argent, ils
vont juste augmenter leur leur
leurs besoins fait avoir une nouvelle
voiture, avoir une meilleure maison,
avoir des voyages puis tout le temps
augmenter son niveau de vie en fonction
de l'argent qui rentre.
Ce qui fait que tu atteins jamais le
stade que tes actifs dépassent l'argent
qui dépenses parce que ça va toujours se
suivre. Tu vas toujours suivre le fait
de OK, je plus d'argent mais OK, je vais
aller me je vais aller me gâter puis je
vais aller augmenter mon niveau de vie.
C'est là que tu t'enfermes dans une
sorte de cage dorée qu'on appelle que tu
es plus capable de redescendre de niveau
fait par exemple ça va être de toujours
t'habiller en luxe aller tout le temps
au rest aller tout le temps avoir tout
le temps du des nouveau chars maison et
cetera dans le dans le luxe mais quand
tu crées ça mais c'est très difficile de
redescendre un niveau puis tu veux tout
le temps monter plus de niveaux donc tu
rentres dans le cerc vicieux de oui tu
crées plus de valeur parce que tu
devienes meilleur dans ce que tu fais
puis et cetera, mais tu augmentes ton
niveau de euh ton niveau de vie tout le
temps. Donc, tu es jamais libre
financièrement, tu es tout le temps
dépendant de travailler.
Donc, c'est qui nous mène à la seconde
partie la vidéo, c'est comment atteindre
ce niveau, comment atteindre cette
liberté financière
le plus rapidement possible.
Donc, ça, il va avoir deux parties à
pour atteindre cette liberté financière.
tu avir la partie ben tes actifs,
l'argent que qui se crée à partir de tes
actifs, donc ton investissement et
cetera, l'argent qui rentre sans que tu
a besoin de travailler
et l'autre partie c'est ton niveau de
vie, l'argent que tu as besoin pour
vivre.
Donc, tu as soit besoin de monter
l'argent que tu crées parce que ton
niveau de vie est élevé ou sinon de
baisser ton niveau de vie, mais tu es
qu'est-ce que tu as besoin pour vivre
pour avoir moins besoin d'actif puis
d'argent qui rentre quotidiennement.
Puis c'est ça qu'on est venu à la à la
discussion, c'est que au final
il y en a qui pensent que il faut je
sais pas moi, 1 million en bourse pour
vivre ta liberté financière parce que 1
million tu fais 1 million par année, je
tuas 1 million dans ton compte de banque
qui est investi puis tu fais du 10 %
average mais du du 8 à 10 % par année
mainant. OK, ben tu fais du 80 100000
par année. Donc ça le monde il disent
OK, ben 80 100000 par année, je suis
capable de vivre avec ça puis je suis
capable de subvenir à mes besoins.
Mais ça c'est si tu restes dans l'idée
de OK, faut que tu a 80000 pour vivre
bien
mais tu as la possibilité
avec l'arbitrage de
faire de l'argent ici par exemple au
Québec
puis déménager. Après ça, il y a la
possibilité de faire ça, tu sais. Il y a
la possibilité d'aller habiter une place
que ça nécessite moins d'argent pour
vivre.
habiter je sais pas moi au Nicaragua en
Amérique centrale
puis d'avoir je sais pas moi là j' des
chiffres je sais pas le niveau de vie ça
ressemblerait à quoi pour habiter là-bas
sur du long terme puis être bien mais tu
dis ça prend 200000 d'investis puis à
chaque année tu fais du 8 10 % tu fais
20000 par année mais si tu habit dans
une place que c'est moins cher d'habiter
Mais je dire avec 20000 en tout cas sûr
que là c'est do mouiller qu'est-ce que
je dis comme chiffre mais vous
comprendrez que tu une place ça nécessit
beaucoup moins d'argent pour vivre
quotidiennement donc ta liberté
financière est beaucoup plus accessible
donc au lieu de viser le 1 million dans
ton compte ben ton ton 1 million qui est
investi,
ben tu peux viser juste 200000 puis de
atteindre le niveau de liberté
financière.
Donc
ça pour dire que c'est atteignable à
tous la liberté financière. Ben tous, je
viens des guill là-dessus, ça dépend de
plein de facteurs mais c'est beaucoup
plus accessible que ce que le monde
croit
puis que tu es un acteur là-dedans pour
décider c'est quoi ton niveau de vie que
tu es capable de vivre avec ça. Puis ben
c'est sûr qu'près ça partie de c'est
créer de la valeur. Apprendre à créer de
la valeur dans ta vie. Puis si les deux
tes contrôles, ben tu es capable de
décider vraiment toi c'est quand tu vas
atteindre ta liberté financière puis
potentiellement le plus rapidement
possible
arriver à ta deuxième phase de vie qui
est OK, j'ai plus besoin d'argent, j'ai
plus besoin de travailler en tant que
salarié pour subvenir mes besoins.
Maintenant je fais quoi ?
Maintenant je fais quoi de ma vie ?
Qu'est-ce que je veux faire réellement ?
Puis ça c'est des questions
qui euh
qui est ultra pertinente à à se poser
pour vraiment avoir une vie qui est
riche de sens pour soi. Puis je pense
qu'il y a pas assez de monde qui se rend
à ce niveau-là parce qu'ils disent
souvent e c'est genre ils vont juste
toujours euh
préférer le le le plaisir court terme
donc à s'acheter des voitures, à
s'acheter du linge, à à s'acheter du du
stock qui euh augmente son niveau de
vie. Mais niveau court terme
que avoir que préférer le bonheur long
terme donc qui va durer toute sa vie par
en descendant son niveau de vie en ayant
la liberté financière et d'avancer vers
ses objectifs qui font du sens pour soi.
Donc euh toutes les questions qui sont
pertinentes à se poser.
J'avais d'autres choses à vous.
Donc c'est ça
ça pour dire la liberté financière est
accessible. plus que tu penses,
faut juste que tu fasses des choix dans
ta vie qui sont en ligés avec ce que tu
veux réellement,
pas juste l'ego de peut-être d'acheter
des autos, des voitures, peu importe,
puis de te questionner vraiment c'est
quoi tu ta vie
pour commencer à vivre le plus vite
possible ta vie, la manière la plus
enigné possible dans tes pour le reste
de ta vie.
Donc je sais pas si cétait clair, je
sais pas si c'était pertinent
mais c'était ça que j'avais le goût de
d'aborder aujourd'hui.
Salut.